make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with the
trinity crisis dark knights metal or
really death metal uh we're back with
trinity crisis right here's the thing
i've been telling you guys this entire
time this is one of these stories you
guys can go out and buy
right like like death metal uh dark
knights metal like these are this is
this is one of those that you just
absolutely have to own
so i do the q a sessions every friday at
6 30 p.m on twitch.tv
comics explained right 6 30 pm eastern
and somebody asked the question
if dc comics has their multiverse and
within their multiverse
is the anti-matter universe where the
anti-monitor resides
then it stands to reason that with that
being the positive multiverse and there
being
a you know dark multiverse that the dark
multiverse would have its own version of
the anti-matter universe and a dark
multiverse anti-monitor and and and my
initial thought was
no i don't think so right i mean because
because it you know i guess it's
possible but it never really occurred to
me this story answers that and there is
[Laughter]
there's a dark multiverse version of the
anti-monitor which is amazing right so
what this does is it initially gives us
kind of this this little bit of a of an
introduction to crises right the way
that the crises on crisis events
worked in the history of dc comics those
of you guys who don't know what that
means um
dc has always kind of launched these
crisis events as a way to kind of reboot
their landscape the last time dc did a
hard reboot with a crisis was during the
original crisis on infinite earth now
before that you even had things like
crisis on earth
earth one and crisis on earth too but
crisis on infinite earths
and then infinite crisis and final
crisis are like the big three from there
you have like
zero hour crisis in time stuff like that
but the idea was that the
events of crisis on infinite earth
basically eliminated the multiverse
but it left some continuity errors in
terms of the characters who existed
zero hour sought to correct some of
those continuity errors and didn't do it
that well
and then you go into infinite crisis
which served the purpose of bringing
back the multiverse even though the
superheroes didn't know about it as well
as making even more changes to the to
the continuity after the original crisis
and then final crisis made the heroes
aware of the multiverse's return
and then added in some more continuity
corrections right as well you know
things like bringing back barry allen
stuff like that but that's basically how
the crisis events worked over the course
of
dc's comics the idea here is that what's
going on now is
in effect a crisis right that's
basically what this is dc hasn't really
advertised it as one but scott snyder is
like
it's essentially a crisis right a crisis
is an event whereby everything could
come to an end and then in some form or
fashion be remade in a way that would
basically suck
and so the idea of the superheroes is to
stop that event from happening that's
basically what this is and so with that
being the case
historically speaking the various
superheroes have usually fought together
in the face of these crisis events but
what wonder woman is pitching here is
what we saw in the last video that we
did where it's basically creating strike
teams and the the team of batman
superman and wonder woman are going to
infiltrate castle bat
that within castle bat is access to the
three major crises that have happened in
dc's history the original crisis
undefeated earth the original infinite
crisis and the original final crisis the
difference here is that while they are
these original crisis events they're the
dark multiverse versions right so
the dark multiverse version of
anti-monitor and superboy prime and dark
side
are awaiting in those particular worlds
not only that those are worlds where the
crises are constantly happening right so
it seemed like they basically never
ended now what we also saw in the last
video is exactly what we're getting here
in the sense that jarrow who's the most
powerful psychic in the entirety of the
dc universe is gonna be the one to
basically help guide them back right
he's gonna get them in there and then
when it's time for them to get out of
those worlds
be their anchor point that will yank
them right out of there right and bring
them back to
castle bat and allow them to get back to
safety to the positive multiverse into
the positive dc universe itself and then
basically save the day the other cool
thing here this is kind of funny
is that a psychic amplifier is created
by mr miracle to help jaro through his
whole process and it's in the shape of a
jar
and he's kind of pissed because he hated
being stuck in a jar but the other funny
thing too
is is kind of like the sort of back and
forth between jonah hex
and and jaro right this is kind of if
i'm being honest i feel like this is
going to end up being like the unsung
hero of this story jonah hex just starts
giving him crap he's like hey like no
offense you know to the starfish there
but can you really block that many minds
and the idea is that jarrow can he can
block the minds of almost anybody within
his immediate vicinity right that's kind
of how the psychic energy works he can't
do it across the entire universe he
can't shield everybody's mind from
everything out there but for the strike
team that's going in there for wonder
woman batman superman he can basically
pull it off
and so with that being the case again
the plan kind of gets reiterated that
martian man hunter and hawk girl are
going to take a team and they're going
to destroy perpetua's throne so they can
basically reroute the energy
to wally when the time comes right
because remember wally west is running
from the batman who laughs and wally
west
contains or at least has the last bit of
dr manhattan's power that the batman who
laughs needs in order to overpower
perpetua and so the idea is to basically
take perpetua's throne from her so that
when the time comes that wally west
passes through they can literally take
the energy that's been accumulated so
far
and the energy from perpetua and pass it
to wally west and then seemingly give
wally the power to destroy
the batman who laughs that kind of seems
to be the case at the same time jon
stewart and the various lanterns are
going to take out the different antennae
that are remaining throughout the
various dark multiversal earths right
where perpetua is absorbing that energy
from is basically what it is think of
the antenna is like straws and she's
drinking
these dark multiverse worlds the energy
that comes off of them it's the easiest
way to think of it but the idea here is
that once these boxes are created right
these teleportation boxes are made then
you basically have wonder woman batman
and superman who teleport to
castle bat now if i'm being honest with
you guys i do love scott snyder scott
snyder's probably one of the best
writers running in dc comics right now
scott snyder man i feel like we have
some missed opportunity here you've got
warbat here who basically looks like
mongol the villain mongol if you if you
became batman or in some
form or fashion was tied into batman
you've got the grim knight who returns
he was a great character i love what
snyder did with him you've got batmazo
so basically like if batman had the
powers of amazo and then you've got mind
hunter right if batman had the powers of
martian manhunter this is
kind of some missed opportunity man like
these are the kind of one shots people
want to see right like origins like how
did batman become amazon how did batman
get the power of martian manhunter how
did batman get the power of mongol like
how did these things kind of coalesce
and come together like that's that's
kind of the funny thing that's that's
what's so interesting about
the death metal run and everything
that's been happening even with dark
knights metal is there could have been
dozens and dozens and
dozens of one-shot stories on these
different batman right like i would
argue dc probably could have gotten away
with about
30 to 35 one shots before people got
tired of it before people were like okay
i don't want to have anything to do with
this anymore i think they probably could
have gotten away with that you know
maybe 30 or 35 is a little high possibly
20 maybe 25 but certainly like a year's
worth of one shots you know just
literally
just release them like every two weeks
over the course of a year and it's just
all these different versions of batman
the issue is that if you don't really
see them anymore
what was what's the point of it if they
appear once of what's the use of that
one shot but it is a cool story and it's
easy money but once they arrive here on
this world the biggest issue they have
to contend with
is how they get past this veritable army
of different batman who are occupying
the main entrance to castle bat and it's
kind of cool because remember they have
swamp thing on their side and one of the
things this one thing hits out here is
that on this world most of the plant
life has been burnt and here's a
question i actually want to ask you guys
sidetrack for a second here's a question
i want to ask you guys
should we record or should we make
videos on the new 52 swamp thing because
i've been thinking about doing that
because dc's releases you know the
releases are kind of
a little hit and miss in me you know hit
and miss for me right now and i kind of
figured it felt like you know keeping
that dc
content going by just covering like
older stories that we never did
right like new 52 swamp thing or new 52
something else or something like that
let me know if you guys want to see that
because we never covered that i thought
it'd be kind of cool but nonetheless uh
swamp thing basically comes to the
realization that they don't really have
to break in guns blazing because if they
did it would be a suicide mission i mean
remember
every one of these batman has in some
form or fashion taken out the justice
league on their own world and so taking
out these guys it would not be hard at
all it'd be the easiest thing
right so that's that's that's one of the
biggest issues that they have and so in
response to that swamp thing says well i
can tap into what's left of the green
he's like i can do what i must and so
once he goes into the green of the world
he in turn beseeches it and he says look
i know there's not a whole lot of you
left and i'm sorry for what it is that i
must do but the green are actually
receptive to it and the green's response
is basically like we're really all this
left on this world and if what little
life that we have left can be done for
the purpose of saving this world and
saving the multiverse itself
all the other aspects of the green
spread throughout all existence that
could easily fall then do what you need
to do because you're doing it in the
name of the greater good
the parliament of trees is fully on
board with this now it does not make
swamp thing
you know godly powerful right it does
not elevate him to like a ridiculous
level of power but what it does do is it
gives him the ability to give them
access under castle bat right to start
opening passageways so they can get to
where they need to go
and because he is essentially one with a
planet now he knows
all the little looks and crannies all
the little caves all the little tunnels
all that kind of stuff so what he lacks
in power
he makes up for in knowledge which is i
would argue in this particular instance
far more important and so because of
that jarrow begins to kind of tap
into what's going on out there basically
begins to look beyond where he is right
now and for the most part
it's kind of snyder just giving us an
update and saying that like the classic
wally west red haired wally west and
then the new 52 wally west barry allen
and jay garrick are all still running
right like they're all still running
trying to outrun the batman who laughs
the issue with this
is despite the fact that they're
speedsters and despite the fact that
they have a huge amount of energy they
can't run forever and i would argue
wally west will be able to run longer
than anybody else one because he
mainlines the speed force right so he
basically has it just pumping directly
into his veins and two the power that he
does have is amplified by the power of
dr manhattan
the other speedsters can stay there to
keep him protected but at the end of the
day it really is just going to kind of
come down to wall-e right and so because
of that
the big concern is that if the batman
who laughs catches up to wally west and
manages to overpower
and kill wally west because it seems
like he probably could then he would
basically absorb what's left of dr
manhattan's powers inside wally and then
following that
take over everything he would kill
perpetua and then seize control of the
multiverse and then recreate everything
in his own image
another thing that kind of goes on here
is a bit of a conversation between jonah
hex and harley quinn now the idea
between this conversation you know
involving these two characters is really
one where they almost kind of see this
as like a suicide squad sort of mission
and the sense of just like hey like
we're basically cannon fodder we were
brought here for the purpose of the fact
that you know if it comes down to it
we're expendable
right like we're we're lives they can
just kind of be tossed away and the
reality is
that's true right wonder woman batman
superman well batman probably would but
the other two wouldn't really say it in
so many words right they wouldn't really
say we brought you here just so we could
throw your lives away if we need to but
that's kind of how it is
that's the reason why like the other
major heavy hitters were thrown out
there right we're basically left out and
to go on their own respective missions
because they can actually pull those
missions off
and so having jonah hex here and having
harley quinn here is kind of like
things go south it's been good knowing
you know that's kind of how it is
it sucks but nonetheless from there you
basically have this massive wall
that kind of stands in their way and
then of course the task comes to
superman to use his x-ray vision and to
see what's on the other side the problem
is that as soon as he does
the wall immediately gets obliterated
and you start seeing these crazy
versions of batman right like you get
black monday which is basically like
batman with the power of solomon grundy
right you get cole who kind of looks
like mira
in batman which is kind of weird cropter
which is an interesting name you get arc
which is like
batman and scarecrow like and it's kind
of cool because we actually get these
sort of
ad hoc explanations here the first bit
of an explanation that we get
is is in the form of arc and this guy
basically says that that he has
all of arkham arkham asylum living
inside his body right and so what
seems to have happened is that in this
dark multiverse world that batman had
basically taken all of
you know the arkham inmates right so
joker riddler uh scarecrow probably
two-face
mr freeze had taken all these different
characters and then just more or less
frankenstein himself
right so you know using the dna of of
killer croc that's probably why he looks
the way he does he's got the cards of
the joker he's got like the hat and the
the kind of uh
he's got the hat of of scarecrow he's
got like the body of
of of clay face if i'm being honest with
you guys i'd say that this could
potentially be the deadliest version of
batman literally he throws one of his
one of his cards at harley she catches
it and it's a card made of clay and it's
one of these things where it could
potentially have taken over her of
course she throws it back but
nonetheless you know
it's a it's a cool little thing here
from there you go into the pearl and the
pearl is not actually batman instead
the pearl is batman's mom and so in that
dark multiverse universe it looked like
bruce wayne as a kid was killed
alongside thomas wayne and she survived
the other one that you get is colt and
cole is actually the daughter of wonder
woman and batman and it's like i kind of
want to see that universe too man you
guys get what i'm saying like like you
have superman who faces off against like
solomon grundy batman
basically and manages to overpower him
you know to a degree but the issue with
this is that as they fight it's one of
these things
where the fight just kind of keeps going
right these guys are designed to
essentially match batman and
and match wonder woman and superman and
so in response to that jarrow ends up
using his powers and basically
overpowering their minds right not only
that also forcing a way open like
forcing a way for them to essentially
escape all these different foes so once
they actually get away they get into
this massive dark space
right this massive like this hugely
empty dark space and it's kind of like
okay like no one really knows what's
going on here but then suddenly with
superman having previously been affected
with anti-life i don't know if you guys
recall that in the early stories when he
was being held by darkseid that
ultimately this leads to him being an
almost kind of
anti-life version of himself detector
right in the sense that he can detect
people like him but more than that he
can detect a super powerful god-like
beast that's near them and this leads to
batman popping a flare only for us to
find out that it's barbados that the
batman who laughs
has captured barbados and i guess it
makes sense it's
crazy it's a ridiculous reveal right
that like barbados is being held in the
basement of castle bat by the batman who
last and it's kind of nuts because
batman's response is like all this is
your fault right like you brought that
laughing thing from from that dark
multiverse from that dark world into the
rest of the multiverse and then like
barbados creates this amazing argument
and he's like no
that's not really true i mean i guess it
kind of is but let me ask you this like
before i rose up and brought him here
my role was that of the forger of worlds
i basically took all these worlds that
were made of nightmares and you know
and and i destroyed them all only the
worlds that were made of dreams were the
ones that were allowed to continue
basically like not the crappy world but
while he ended up basically defecting
along his path he said like in
in the last years i watched my realm
filled with nightmare planets with more
nightmare planets than
ever world upon world of anger and
selfishness and fear and hate and all i
did was bring my realm here for you to
see
so who's the bigger cause of all this
the person who brought these dark worlds
up to your multiverse or you guys the
ones who created them
in the first place now from there you
basically end up picking up with uh with
the robin king right this was a version
of bruce wayne
who didn't really grow up to become
batman then in the immediate aftermath
of his parents dying he basically
started concocting plans to like conquer
crime more or less so basically like
using a kid's imagination to become the
darkest version of himself that he could
imagine and and one of the things that
happens here is of course he kind of
shows up now the robin king is also a
bit of an enigma we know he's comes from
the dark multiverse he's an evil version
of bruce wayne but we've kind of seen
instances over the course of the story
so far where he almost kind of has
helped
the heroes out a little bit and so it's
kind of like okay like is he a true like
a full-on villain well this question
kind of gets answered in the sense that
he basically ends up taking on like like
swamp thing jonah hex and uh and harley
quinn and it's one of these things where
he kind of explains a bit of his history
right
and saying that like for him when he has
his utility about his utility about is a
kid's imagination utility belt in the
sense that he can use it for any number
of things like when he goes and faces
off against swamp thing what he contains
inside his utility belt is the rock
right the one thing that can basically
take out swamp thing right like is his
mortal enemy the mortal enemy of the
green and so he literally takes it and
and throws it at swamp thing right and
using that
begins to kind of decay the green which
in turn starts to decay swamp thing from
there for harley quinn harley quinn in
his universe tracked him down
pretty fast like she figured out what he
was doing pretty quickly she came
running up on him with a mallet he ended
up beating her to death with it and then
with jonah hex what he ends up doing is
firing a gun
that while jonah hex is already dead
technically speaking the bullet that's
fired is designed to break down the
crowd of
necrotic tissue so literally dissolve
jonah hex which is exactly what happens
so jonah hex really kind of falls from
there it leads to swamp thing grabbing
jaro and harley and getting out of there
the issue with this is that
jarrow was the means by which batman
superman and wonder woman were going to
be yanked out of those particular
universes and brought back to castle
back so they could make their escape but
the further away jaro is the more
difficult it'll be for him to be their
psychic anger and potentially they could
just be stuck out in the in those
universes forever they could be stuck in
those respective worlds and so with each
one with batman superman and wonder
woman seizing their their own box uh
what it does is it teleports them to
their own particular realm the first one
is the events of crisis on defended
earth now what wonder woman's been
saying here the entire time and what
what snyder had been
been telling us is that because of what
was going on in the sense of
these are the crisis events that are
perpetually happening meaning they're
constantly happening that when they
arrive here the idea is that they're
going to show up what it what is an
effect
in the middle of the crisis right so it
would be like it's like it's kind of
like a vendors end game where like they
were using the time stone and they were
just showing up when things were
happening so like during the avenger the
the original avengers movie the
incredible hulk showed up in the middle
of the chittari invasion that was kind
of the expectation here and they could
basically turn the tide of the conflict
to their success and actually
end the crisis on that world because of
the crisis is constantly happening and
these worlds exist because the batman
who last made them to ensure that crisis
energy
perpetually exists so that perpetua can
can absorb that crisis energy and keep
herself powerful that it stands to
reason the best way to cut her off from
that energy source is to end the crises
on these worlds and so with that being
the case
the first location we get is the crisis
on infinite earth but instead of showing
up in the midst of a massive conflict we
basically show up
in a giant white space right and this by
all standards of measurement
looks like the anti-matter universe it
looks like the anti-monitor one
and we're kind of given this look this
little kid version of the anti-monitor
right that almost kind of seems to be
just living existence completely and
totally you know like in this entirety
it's it's kind of weird but from there
you jump to the final crisis and then
you basically end up having superman
arriving here where he's attacked by
superman as well as darkseid who's kind
of standing over everything and
superman's like no this is this is not
how it's supposed to be this is not how
the final crisis happened like we
defeated darkseid like we basically won
and darkseid's like no this is exactly
how
everything should be right and then from
there you get into the infinite crisis
and as soon as wonder woman shows up
she's immediately attacked and it's kind
of like what in the world is going on
here and that's when she basically looks
up and she's kind of like i don't
understand right like this is not right
i don't remember this moment happening
in the infinite crisis and the response
to this person here is like that's
because it didn't happen
in these various crisis events in the
dark multiverse version of crisis
infinite earth the anti-monitor won the
anti-monitor defeated
all the superheroes and recreated
reality right he took he destroyed the
specter and he destroyed everything and
recreated the whole multiverse in his
own image wiped out all existence and
there was just
the anti-anti-matter universe left
during the events of infinite crisis
superboy prime overpowered all the
superman he was never defeated and
during the events of final crisis
darkseid's anti-life equation took hold
he conquered the world
and all the superheroes in it and that's
exactly what dark multiverse superboy
prime says
when he looks on to diana prince when he
looks under one wonder woman he says
i am super boy prime and on these crisis
worlds wonder woman
all of you lost with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob corp if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like i will catch
you all later
peace
so
[Music]
you